foreign
the three Muslims how you guys doing
today man
um
I guess Angel wasn't feeling too good
man all right that's it boys
to everyone
feels like it's been forever sorry it's
been so long man I know bro it's been
it's been what a month since we did a
stream two weeks since we dropped the
video what's going on
Savannah
yeah buddy
how's everyone doing everyone in the
chat
all right looks like on who's back
someone else what did Destiny do
we're gonna get into that not too much
in depth but
more of just like a overarching theme
I've been seeing with a lot of YouTubers
all right
said bombs I know
no
Hamza I did say put out like a I didn't
watch it but he's putting out a video
scheduled where he said uh like he
completed his mission goodbye or
something like that
um
oh really
yeah that's what Tick-Tock does angel
are you a solo fee bro
I mean
linguistically
a solar system or follows the sort of uh
the prophet Muhammad
and the companions
ain't nothing wrong with that bad
definition I mean that's what we are
but hey y'all y'all Choose Yourself
y'all don't believe what you wanted to
leave
I uh I wanted to tell you guys a
beautiful story because my teacher just
told me in it honestly it made me want
to cry a little bit or a lot so um he
sent me a voice message and he was like
oh it's not working Mommy I hope you're
watching a lot and he was like
um a sister joined one of my classes and
she said that two years ago she started
looking to Islam and she found some
sisters at school who were Muslims so
she asked them about it but the answer
they gave just it didn't sit right with
her and then later she went to like I
think a Masjid uh and spoke to an Imam
and the answer he was given just it
didn't say well with her either so she
was like
I kind of left it for a bit and
I came across some videos on YouTube
and that's what took me uh that's what
pushed me to take the step and actually
accept the snap and just finally move
forward and my teacher because this is
in his class right he's teaching at
seven class he's like I could have asked
any question but I I was curious I'm
like oh really what like what did you
see
and then she was like you know that
Channel the three Muslims
and my teacher's like man I wanted to
cry she was like he was like you know
ROM used to be my student
s subhanallah
bro subhanallah
Miller accept the followers
I mean I mean
um
I like real life stories mashallah I do
too
so brothers let's give a quick update to
the family because they're probably
wondering where have we been you know
uh so we actually went to Amura about a
few weeks ago hamdullah was a very good
trip do you two wanna speak a little bit
about your experience because this was
my second omra but this was your first
for both of y'all uh let the viewers
know how it was
Alhambra
I'll let you go first bro because you
have gotten sick
so I want to hear you behind a lot bro
someone just commented that yeah
um his name is his name is Farhad he's a
great brother manual bless him
so um
yeah my Umbra was amazing I mean my
journey didn't didn't just start at
umrah all right I actually started at
Medina
when we prayed and measured in nabawi
and um
we we buried the bodies you know that
was the first
man that hit me like a truck it hit me
like 100 semi trucks bro it we I don't
know we buried a kid man the first I I
was carrying the coffin it was heavy
right so I didn't I think anything of it
and then I I see them bring the body
down it's it's a kid and it just breaks
my heart I'm thinking this could have
been me at that age you know this may
Allah protect us and our families this
could be my child you know this could be
me burying my child's subhanallah and
it's just
it hit me so man I was I was walking
back and knowing that Medina is the
first place where the process
established Islam
it just it really just penetrated my
heart and all that's why if you guys
remember I was I was crying like crazy
and I was walking back and I just kept
saying
it really hit me like what does that
mean
what does that mean that means there is
no one nothing nobody you even really
think about obeying over Allah no matter
who it is you have one person who you
obey one person who you worship one
person who you work for one person who
you sacrifice for the only reason you're
on this Earth
there's nothing except him and the rest
obviously is beautiful just emphasizing
how amazing Allah is
and it just it hit me and then when I
got to Mecca and I saw the Kaaba and I
was doing Umbra
uh I mean it didn't really
it didn't really hit me then because I
think all the people
you know I I thought all the people was
they were making it a bit difficult to
focus I didn't want to hit anyone I was
getting bodied by old ladies but
then I got down to to where the camera
is I got close to it and that's what I
think really did it for me subhanallah
bro like your your experience was um
not as good as you would have liked it
to be since you guys sick yeah yeah
sorry you mentioned that and I
completely forgot about it yeah so I got
I got the uh
yeah I don't know if I should say it on
here or not I was debating but yeah I
got covered
and I didn't know it was covered until
like the last two days I had it and um
man I was drained I've not felt I don't
think I felt that sick in my life
alhamdulillah which is the blessing from
Allah but it was it was beautiful
because
at first I was like I'm I'm gonna die
and that's how I felt and then I
realized that you know it's it's
beautiful because I'm about to go for
umrah Allah is expiating my sins the
ones that were too big the ones that I
didn't repent for the ones I forgot
about I didn't ask a lot to forgive me
Allah insha Allah
was cleansing me of those sins so it
just
it made me very happy to look at it from
that perspective so then when I I was
when I still felt drained and I was
doing Umbra feeling drained
it was difficult but every step I took
I'm like you know it's it's inshallah
even more reward because it's more
difficult
yeah
um
bless you and I'm glad to hear that
you're doing better
how about you was your first umra
yeah it was my first umra it was
beautiful but I'll be honest I felt like
I was in shock the entire time
and it wasn't until I got to the Cava
when we were playing Maghrib at the car
but that's when like it really hit me
and uh I started crying
but it's it's just like you said you
know everybody's like pushing and
shoving so it kind of made it hard like
the very first
murder that we did it was uh very hard
to focus on the duas and just you know
close to Allah in that time like you
said there's
there's these like little
hit these little bowling balls
like bowling balls they they slam into
you and the weight's so download and
it's like you can't help but to just
like fall back yeah
I mean
yeah it was it was a life-changing
experience to be honest
yeah yeah how about you
bro honestly my first one was a little
bit
more intimate and the reason being is in
the the first omra that I went on it was
during covid right so because of that
and I know you know there's still cool
video but uh at least during like you
know where there were harsher
restrictions you know and because of
that not many people like I don't know
if you guys remember like those aerial
shots of the Kaaba where it was empty it
was deserted and that's exactly like the
type of environment that I went on so
it's very empty not that many people I
was able to uh make tawaf barely anyone
there like y'all remember when we went
there right the Haram like the main
floor with the Kaaba it was Max Capacity
we couldn't even go there when we
started omra
I think even like the first floor
like around it was Max Capacity so I
think we were on the second or third
floor when you started right
and I was telling Angel like bro almost
a breeze it's like an hour or two hours
max you know just like to do tawaf and
to do side right so when we went because
we weren't in the Kaaba like the farther
you go diameter wise your circumference
is higher too so our flipping first
tawaf itself took like 40 minutes to 60
Minutes I kid you not and at that point
we were like bro this is about to take
10 to 15 hours this is this is no joke I
believe
we were all together and then I think
somehow we lost around me and me and
anho we tried looking for Romney we
couldn't but then we found this like
loophole going into the main Haram like
it just opened up bro subhanallah so we
didn't think twice we just took it got
to the Haram and then Rami came shortly
after and then we all met up when we
were doing Safa in marwa and
alhamdulillah we finished it
yeah that's another part I if someone
understands why please let me know I was
doing tawaf on the upper part and then I
I got to a place where I don't know
where my camera is glitching but I got
to a place where they just put a
blockade across the whole walkway and
but I thought to the right was open and
then I can go further out and do tawaf
even farther which is going to take
longer but that's that's what's open so
I went and then I keep walking I get to
another blockade I'm like what is this
so I walk all the way back keep in mind
it's been like 25 minutes of walking now
right just on that like since I hit that
first blockade so I go back and I wait
for another like 25 minutes it's almost
been an hour and then the then foreign
this whole time and you guys blocked me
like for seemingly no reason I'm not
even close to the Kaaba like what is
this for and then I was walking and I
got to that same place where they have
the stairs going down to the actual
Haram in the Kaaba in mokama Ibrahim and
all that
and I think since they just released a
blockade and I just got there there
weren't many people down there and
that's why something that I was able to
kind of like you know shimmy my way
through while doing two off to get to
the cabin so I I didn't get to touch the
black stone I was close but
alhamdulillah that was a blessing from
Allah so I had to wait a little bit but
alhamdulillah was rewarded so
guys t3m I'm gonna Vlog coming soon
Insha'Allah uh ano what do you think
about Romy with the shaved head
lose problem man how's the hair growing
back right now it's um it's a lot
thinner than I thought it would look but
it's uh
you're gonna just shave it
I'm gonna grow it back he's growing it
up bro I told him to keep it short
yeah but we should always just keep it
shaved yeah the three the three shaves
most of us no no no I'm gonna grow mine
now I'm gonna look nice and cute
bro come on I'm gonna look nice and cute
inshallah
I had a crush on Romney just found out
he is married I'm crying right now stock
for Allah
I should be saying Allah
come on the definition of has said bro
Envy is when you not only want something
or admire something that someone has but
you wish you had it too come on now
I mean
Oh I thought this is the Warner bro
where you at inshallah with him right
yeah they know we were with him and
shall it'll be on them oh yeah because
that was a lot that was a great time man
yeah more to come inshallah
so boys before we uh go a little bit
deeper into the stream we've been
getting a lot of DMS t3m where you guys
taking your foot off the gas what's
going on it's been it's been two three
weeks since a video a month plus since a
live stream you know you guys were
consistent or you guys falling off or
you guys burnt out what's going on
so I think it's no better than Rami to
uh kind of address a little bit about
this restructuring or re-strategization
that we've been implementing into our
channel inshallah that we want to
implement going forward uh no we are not
going off the wall or off the radar but
there are going to be some changes
inshallah
yeah inshallah so it's a bit difficult
to talk about this because we don't want
to go too much into detail and on I
think on the front end what you guys see
is not going to look too different
you're going to notice some changes
maybe but it's not going to look too
different we're still going to be doing
the live streams still going to be
making our videos maybe a few less
reactions and all that stuff and more
just you know General wholesome content
from us about things we want to and need
to discuss as brothers
and as you know people online but the
main change is going to be within
ourselves if you guys watch the shooter
episode you can see there was a
discussion where you know we were
basically talking about how we need to
fix ourselves we need to work on
ourselves we need to be better as
Muslims and as men if we're going to be
you know online giving dawa so
you guys might notice
growth Insha'Allah um from us in the
next few months the next year a lot more
than the last two years inshallah so
that's what we want to focus on we want
to underfo we want to understand you
know you brothers and sisters more we
want to understand what it means to be
the best podcasters we really want to
take this to the next level inshallah
and do more episodes like we did with
shooter you know the in person sit down
and and talk about real things
Insha'Allah um that's kind of my summary
if you guys want to jump in please do
in someone
I don't think we should say all the
plans but I think that it is pretty much
the best thing to do at the moment in
time just you know review everything
right now it's like everyone's gonna
expect that like what if that's not even
exactly what we're gonna do we're gonna
do something to kind of dip yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely yeah I agree why
don't we why don't we tease them do you
guys think we should tease them about
the next guest in person potentially
inshallah
um yeah go for it okay all right so we
just got in touch with uh brother I am
Lucid who uh humbled I've been talking
to for a while but things just it took
this long for things to be in the
perfect time and perfect place
so we are considering inshallah meeting
up doing an in-person podcast maybe some
vlogging too with brother Alex I'm Lucid
if you guys know him on YouTube I don't
know if you guys know him if you don't
you're probably living under a rock come
on what are you doing but uh inshallah
coming in the next few weeks
that that episode has been a long time
coming man so alhamdulillah Allah best
of planners
[Music]
foreign
so um yeah so how how can the brothers
and sisters watching this stream and
watching the channel help by just making
dot for us inshallah that Allah makes us
leaders for the righteous I mean and
brothers from uh I know where this
brother's from because it says four one
it's like Toronto there you go yeah I
don't want to expose that but okay bro
it literally says love Toronto
that could be anything T.O that's true
that's true you're not wrong yeah but he
says uh so first come for the uh they
don't know fifty dollars bless you he
says thank you guys for all the work you
guys are doing because of you guys I
worship Allah again well that's only
because of Allah he used us and that's a
blessing for us alhamdulillah just like
it's a blessing for you and I ask Allah
to forgive me for being so arrogant
about his existence I mean I think many
people have fallen down that hole
unfortunately because of the LIE of new
age atheism but Allah says in the Quran
the truth is distinct from falsehood and
he says when when truth comes falsehood
vanishes alhamdulillah
inshallah inshallah I guess people are
hyped for Lucid inshallah next don't
know
just a rough estimate inshallah I want
to go with my family soon Mela reward
everyone who went this is the most
commonly asked question that I'm getting
right now from friends and family I
would say about three to four K total
um this is in CAD by the way so maybe
2.5 to 3.2 ish kusd
um if you go now however it will be
significantly cheaper if you go around
let's say August September October
November
um and right now it's it's Ramadan it's
coming so it's going to be the peak Peak
and it's crowded so I don't recommend
unless you guys want to get that extra
azure
inshallah uh who you can do cheaper to
be honest but you have to sacrifice
comfort at that point
um
so Rami he's there bro yeah I'm just
give me 30 seconds let me like rewire my
tickets and tickets on
so brother teller writes Allah save me
from fentanyl addiction I almost off to
myself three times and got back every
time Allah
just remember this to anyone suffering
with being addicted to any substance
understand that Allah has saved you once
or twice or multiple times thus far till
this point there is no guarantee that
Allah will save you next time
so don't mess around with the mercy of
Allah don't play around with
with uh the patience of Allah with the
grace and kindness of Allah that Allah
has brought you back this many times
for every time that you come back you
repent and you say you won't do it again
and you make promises and false Oaths
with Allah
and then every time you slip into it you
think that Allah is going to forgive you
every single time coming forward
but what Assurance gives you that
guarantee
because next time
if God forbid something happens to you
you can't say oh Allah this was going to
be the last time Allah if only you gave
me one more shot
you feel me
yeah
there we go there we go one more second
Bismillah
okay my bad
spot online
laughs
brother otherwise Channel about three
days ago and to be said it is phenomenal
you gained a lot of knowledge about
Islam thank you uh Brothers
we are
nowhere near where we want to be in
terms definitely not definitely not
Abdullah
someone wrote fired your eyes mashallah
bless you
um
guys stay on the topic Oscar writes did
you guys react to Destiny's Muslim
tweets let's let's talk about this right
now
yeah so we're not gonna go in depth into
this because this video is not to be
dissecting uh any liberal uh
I gotta watch what I say right now but
you guys get what I mean the main thing
that we want to address is what's kind
of going on with these islamophobes and
ex-muslims that are basically painting a
false narrative about Islam because
there are a group of people that want to
just follow their nuffs but they want to
do it scot-free guilt-free so Rami do
you want to dress this a little bit
yeah so
Destiny and kind of like these people
who go out of their way to insult Islam
you know a lot of people on the surface
level who don't know what's going on
they think oh they're just exercising
Free Speech they're just blah blah blah
think about it from their perspective
why do they need to post a picture
that's only offensive to Muslims what
does it do for them why do they need to
say a statement that
if Muslims didn't I don't say Muslims
exist but like if it didn't bother
Muslims they probably would not be
posting it
they want to go out of their way to
offend Muslims to offend Islam and if
you look at that person in particular
he put out a tweet or two kind of
insinuating that Muslims are just
violent online and when you say anything
that's negative about the religion
they're going to threaten you and attack
you and then he put horrible things
about you know our religion going out of
his way to disrespect Muslims and of
course like anyone and anything else he
received a lot of threats and a lot of
backlash and a lot of absolute hate and
tweets and his DMS as well and then he
posted them like well I guess I was
right which is really really silly
because if you provoke any group of
people you're gonna have that kind of
response so I don't know what he's
trying to prove but I don't think he
really cares about what's morally right
or wrong I genuinely think people like
him just want to have a goat Muslims I
don't know why but I don't see any other
reason other than just maybe they're
bored or maybe they want to go after
Muslims
I'm not sure
I mean he's not wrong like the
there's a lot of Muslims bro when you
say something that they get real violent
and they uh start attacking you online
so he's correct in that regarding is it
proper
[Music]
um
World ambassadors of Islam
so how you
how you handle
people disrespecting our Dean
and what you show is going to be what
they interpret as
Islam unfortunately because what better
representation of Islam than actual
Muslims
even though we know Islam is perfect but
Muslims are not but you know whether you
like it or not we are representing Islam
and that's a big responsibility to carry
especially when you're out here cursing
and making allegations threats to people
that are you know attacking the Deen now
they could be out of ignorance right
think about it have some type of empathy
I'm not saying all of them are are you
know to be trusted or to be given that
level of benefit of the doubt right but
they could be jahil bro if somebody
really internalized the true Message of
Islam and Allah do you really think they
would be making these videos yeah a lot
of them are like apos and David wood
potentially
um but do you really think everyone is
arrogant and not ignorant so we have to
understand
damn bro
I think uh some people are gonna listen
to me what you said and they're going to
take that as like softness but it's not
about being soft it's about being
intelligent emotionally intelligent and
understanding that there are certain
times where you have to react to things
in a certain manner so that you can
approach things in the best way and you
can actually have an impact with your
words and you know reaching out to this
certain individual that you may be
trying to
I don't know get some kind of
understanding with it yeah bro I think I
think softness if anything would be if
somebody could just you know throw you
off your Square just with a little bit
of an insult bro
and you're off center now I think that
would be weak if anything but around me
do you want to talk about the story of
the postal song
um when he was in the graveyard and how
he he didn't go off on that mother
but he handled it with emotional
intelligence and how that strengthened
our weakness
yeah so the prophet Allah He Came Upon a
woman crying at um one of her family
members Graves I don't know who it was
but someone she loved dearly and um
subhanallah I don't remember exactly
what she said to the process time
initially but the prophet peace be upon
him he said something to her I gave her
some advice or you know just said a few
words and then she like lost it she
didn't know it was the process of him
because her back was turned to him but
she yelled at him and you know
and then the prophet saw them you know
he is the messenger of Allah there is a
literal Ayah in the Quran that Allah
revealed saying don't raise your voice
to the prophet he could have pulled this
out he could have said do you know who
you're talking to he could have you know
went off on her but he just walked away
he walked away he didn't say anything
and now another example I think maybe
something that's a little even more
related to this and everyone can put
themselves in this position the
prophetam was sitting with Abu Bakr His
companion his closest friend
and the non-muslims were insulting them
and Abu Bakr stayed silent across the
Sun States Island
and then Abu Bakr just couldn't take it
anymore because they went from insulting
him to insulting the process and that's
when he's okay enough
and he got up he started yelling back
and as soon as he started yelling back
the process suddenly walked away
and he said when you were patient and
you weren't saying anything the Angels
were gathering around or there's a
Hadith that says when people are cursing
you and insulting you and you stay
silent the angel comes and defends you
so imagine an angel
is defending you to this person
right obviously they don't see her here
but the angel is defending you and this
you know shaitaan or this whoever it is
that's insulting you there are nobody at
the end of the day
you got up and started yelling I walked
away because the Angels dispersed and
I'm not I don't go to places where there
are not Angels so what does it say for
us
it says that when we are dealing with
these people
you can refute what they're saying you
can engage with them you should engage
with them you should defend your
religion but it's not attacking someone
is not Defending Your religion that's
quite often actually especially when
like when you look at this situation
what are you doing what is it going to
accomplish that you threaten him
nothing all you're doing is giving him
exactly what he wants because he posted
a picture and people like him they do
this they insult Islam and Muslims then
some half crazy hot head and Muslims go
and insult and whatever Lord knows who
they are if they're 13 year olds or if
they're actually older men who are a
little unhinged you know sending all
these horrible things and they take a
screenshot I'm posting online say oh
look Muslims are XYZ you're not helping
the situation at all it's much better
just to discuss why he's wrong of all
he's saying or why his opinion doesn't
really mean anything in whatever he's
talking about then just to go and and
attack people
um
yeah 100 agree bro
y'all know we got a invitation to the
Stream
with um I think destiny
we got an invitation
I'm gonna take the uh Discord
I've been I've been a little bit of
money from the Discord bro I remember
yeah
come on now
I love you for the sake of Allah too bro
guys if you're in Illinois in America
United States of America come on go to
Faith 48 Barbershop and get right
brother below will hook you up inshallah
beautiful brother
some excited to see you again real soon
inshallah
Leo writes when are you brothers getting
Dao overdonia on inshallah soon
rates when you threaten them they are
going to respond in the same way
you're encouraging them to attack Sun
exactly
guys it takes two to argue it takes two
to quarrel it takes two to fight one
person can't just fight another person
that's not a fight that's an attack you
feel me so understand that
um yes we do have era for the Deen we do
have a lot of intolerance for disrespect
for sure nobody's saying anything about
it
but you got to pick and choose which
battles you want to fight
and how that's going to make Islam look
to the non-muslims to the kofar and to
the the hills the ignorance among
Society how that's going to look
and think about that before you act not
act and then be like oh okay I didn't
know any better sure we can learn from
our mistakes but it's better to not make
these mistakes and take preemptive
measures than to kind of do damage
control
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely
and this is why it's important to learn
your Dean by the way right
man I'll bless you bro this is why it's
important to learn your religion because
when you when you're in the situation
where okay you have to defend this time
you have to know what you're talking
about you can't just make things up and
say random things that's sinful you know
uh to lie about Slammer to make things
up on the spot even if you think that
you're defending Islam because what if
you say something about Islam about
Allah about the prophet Allah that's not
true right you would be sinful so you
have to learn your religion and a part
of learning your religion is learning
good character the process
he said the heaviest thing on the scale
is good character he said I did not come
for anything except the perfect good
character many many sahih Hadith
emphasizing this to the point where some
you know I I don't remember which was
exactly but one of the four main um
Scholars from the form of ahib his mom
sent him to go learn under Scholars and
he he went he learned and he came back
and he said you know I learned this and
I learned that and his mom sent him back
because he didn't learn manners he
learned the knowledge but he didn't
learn manners he didn't learn how to
convey the message so his mother may
Allah bless her sent him back to go
learn that stuff so it's a lesson for
all of us you know learning Islam is an
obligation
and teaching Islam is an obligation once
you know
so take it seriously
um
[Music]
I know bro you've been awfully quiet
right now
just listening man just listening Mela
make us as you see us
so did you find it on the Discord no I
didn't want to look too distracted on
the stream but I was looking I there's
so many channels I I don't know which
one to take it's um it was on a ticket I
could send in the group chat right now
please please do inshallah
give me something
next Super Chat I don't mean do you want
to read it out
uh would you would you like to talk to
Destiny on this topic there's a panel
where he will discuss this tomorrow if
you want to
um I would like more information what
are we discussing exactly or he's
talking about you know how we have
Interfaith dialogues are we talking
about like the marriage of eyeshadow
just give me more information inshallah
and who's going to be on this uh panel
as well
hmm
all right
well I was like welcome welcome send
Destiny to STL St Louis I'll take care
of him real well inshallah bro inshallah
Skye
we'll leave it at night send the group
chat to you so y'all can check it I
don't know why my camera is so damn
close right now bro what the hell is
this
um can you can you message me or the
three Muslims on Instagram
damn man bro just like that
coming to your streams makes my Iman
fresh
from Allah
can we get a beard care tutorial from
Angel I don't know he's not here
um I don't know about hispanic you could
say Latino in Spanish
Hispanic is Latino so it's fine is it uh
Puerto Rico
Puerto Rico I love the way Dr Steph
Curry says Puerto Rico
how do you say
he says the proper way bro I don't even
want to attempt it right now
like in Spanish
yeah
Puerto Rico
there's an l
no it sounds like it oh but it's not ill
damn bro
[Laughter]
how was umbrella come on man you late to
the party we talked about in the
beginning
yeah you got to rewind inshallah uh Mr
Clean man 2.0 around me I love you for
the sake of shake of Allah come on now
bro are you gonna do a typo like that
love you for loving me for his sake
Allah I mean rights who are you going to
do a podcast with next Bros so inshallah
we already talked about I am Lucid
um one of the big guests the big homie
that we wanted to have on inshallah
unfortunately we can't right now because
of the life circumstances the real ones
know who he is inshallah when he's out
we'll go from there right away with
quickness no hesitation
oh let's see
Baldi check I already did mine I already
did mine it's on you guys now yeah it is
inshallah next stream I'll do mine and
the next stream we'll do it on her and
then uh
guys what are we gonna do about uh yes
Masha Allah I knew it grew up around a
lot of Hispanic friends
what are your thoughts on uh uh people
that are Muslim like till this day
from all we know
all other things aside they're Muslim
apparently
um but they're out here still hating on
Tate and still slandering him without
evidence being like Oh it's amazing
alhamdulillah he's still locked up and
stuff like that I hope he never gets
free stuck for a lot
just imagine yourself in that position
that's it just imagine yourself in that
position and then repeat the same
statement
it's upon Allah I'm talking like that
ass locked up for months
at no habitable living conditions and
you don't know when you're gonna get out
yeah you really think you want to test
that it's easy to say when it's someone
else yeah and I think this is the
clearest sign that these people are pure
Hypocrites right and I'm not saying
they're like actually manafia playing in
Islam I'm talking about that a lot of
the the people who I've seen online who
really just hate brother Andrew
as soon as they see an injustice against
them they get either happy or they don't
care they Overlook it I've not seen the
people who spoke out against them you
know the online lawyers or the the
online pseudo lawyers or the online
haters I've never seen any of the people
who dislike him actually say listen the
way they're treating him and locking
them up for this long is wrong it's a
violation of international law even
though in Romanian law it's like
technically permissible it's abnormal in
Romanian law they don't usually do this
you know I've never heard anyone who
dislikes saying that but the Muslim we I
I have criticized Tate in the past I can
only use myself an example I don't
really watch other people's content on
him I have criticized some of the things
he said in the past and I've prayed some
of the things that he's done
because
as human beings we have to be fair
people will say good people will say bad
people will be right people will be
wrong everyone myself included
and if you want to be fair you have to
be willing to acknowledge the rights of
people and the wrongs of people and he
has a right over us as Muslims
especially people on the outside people
with platforms people online to call
into question
the
Integrity of the claims against him to
call into question the Integrity of the
people who are fighting against him who
are trying to get him locked up you know
x amount of months and there has not
been any evidence now I understand how
you know to the best Mobility how
investigations go I know not every
little thing they get they're gonna
throw up you know against the wall for
everyone to see
but there has been nothing admitted thus
far you know and they are obligated to
let the defense know anything for or
against him that will be admitted into
the course so
it's completely unfair the way they've
been treating him it's abnormal from
what I hear because I'm not 100 sure
it's abnormal in Romanian law to hold
them for that long and I ask Allah to
bring the truth to light
and Insha'Allah if he's innocent make it
clear to the people and release him so
he can come back insha Allah and um
Proclaim Islam to the people teach the
people about Islam and learn it for
himself I mean
but he's gone again bro I don't know
what I'm gonna do with this it's a
pattern no we need to call him out on
Hell exposed yeah but one time okay two
times nah
three times come on
four times you're off the show yeah
Allah bless him
I mean I mean I mean I'm I'm very sure
he will I'm very sure he will inshallah
from what I've heard from people close
to him
this is not something that's going to
break him especially and you know what
forget everything else forget who he is
how strong he might be how resilient he
might be forget all that he has the
Quran
all he has to do is read the Quran you
know how much of a blessing it is that
Allah allowed him to enter the cell with
his Quran
subhanallah
that's all you need man yeah
and I like I really like the way shooter
framed it he was like Allah
basically put him in the only position
in life where he'd be forced to sit with
the Quran alone
he wouldn't stop working he'd be he'd
keep grinding and the Dunya and all that
stuff Allah forced him in a situation
where he has to read the Quran and I
think that there's Beauty to that
alhamdulillah
is there anything you want to touch on
bro before Arnold comes back people I I
actually wanted to ask people about this
and a few people were kind of giving
answers before I even asked
I've I've I actually like Destiny I I
like his content generally speaking I
used to like his stuff I think he tries
to be fair more often than a few other
people
and this is not on any particular topic
this is just in general from what I've
seen from him
so I want to know what people thought
about us going on and I feel like in
this topic it would be almost completely
useless because I don't think he's
willing or wants to or cares to learn
take a step back if he's wrong or
anything based on his tweets I think he
literally he just wants a fight he just
wants to you know try and make Muslims
in Islam look bad and I think he just
genuinely wants to
um argue about this topic if I'm being
honest and just hate on Islam and I
think a few of the people were saying
that as well in the comments so I want
the inshallah almost 400 people in here
give your opinion if you are familiar
with him on what you think if it would
be beneficial to talk to him or if he's
a person who's just insincere and not
willing to listen first comment right
away Ali writes I hate him
isn't there a principle
or something like that yeah yeah we have
to we have to love what Allah is pleased
with and we have to I guess forego what
Allah is this pleased with
um but at the end of the day how do you
know that this person's intention is
actually what you claim it to be yeah we
gotta love and hate for the sake of
Allah but do you really think he's
ignorant or arrogant Someone Like A Plus
bro call us he's gonna have to do a lot
to prove himself back if you ever want
to come back into Islam but Destiny it's
a little bit too quick to tell JP I
don't know it's like at this point not
there's he's gonna have to do a lot to
to earn even despite being an academic
and uh someone that's been an
intellectual in the academic Sphere for
a long time everything he's been doing
recently no but with Destiny I don't
know it might be too too early to tell
another one writes destiny let's let's
not let's not listen I I didn't ask for
any insults I don't want no insults
let's keep it to that Destiny has an
Unholy lifestyle he's about role model
um anyone talking about him basically
allowing his girl to sleep around okay
let's I don't see I don't see because I
see a lot of these comments I don't want
to pin them up they're not relevant to
necessarily what is at hand about him
and his uh you know some people are
making a false qualification about
somebody who does that doesn't have a
moral High Ground I guess that could be
an argument at the very least
um but right now we are talking
specifically about his slandered and
attacking towards Islam so let's keep it
at the uh has lung cancer may Allah make
it easy on him uh
there have been yeah different things
said about that let's just let's leave
it inshallah okay next Destiny comments
it doesn't do anything
and what does that mean like he's
sincere but he's a clowns like what does
that means he's a sincere clone or
you just be fair but he is I think
everyone's like that you know everyone's
gonna not be fair at some point in life
everyone has biases but if he's trying
you know that I think that's good
yeah well like bro lie yeah at the end
of the day I think this is the perfect
definition I have ever seen from coldest
on summing up liberalism
because this is literally what they
portray as liberals subhanallah yeah
yeah
I I really think liberalism is useless
bro I genuinely think it's useless
all it's saying is like
he was a human being have desires go for
it don't think or worry about anyone
else make your money live your life
please your own you know Neffs your own
private parts and then die but we don't
talk about death we pretend it doesn't
exist until it hits like a truck and
then you fall into massive depression
and then want to do something to
yourself which the rate is is high maybe
even going higher now of that thing
especially amongst men because Society
is built not for the community but for
the individual to screw off until they
realize that there's no point to
hedonism
slug is the real question is exactly
what jewel said why are we living in a
field Society
yeah
yeah but we spoke about that we spoke
about that yeah
um
okay
uh the Nelson
two knows all the leaked evidence have
been one-sided all the leaked evidence
have been one-sided uh what are you
talking about
um
yeah I think there has been like there
there have been like kind of foreign
against things but
regardless it doesn't need to respect to
our beloved Prophet saws
um no way will I have a single answer
respect for him yeah I mean I that's
that's understandable I I even tweeted
that his his respect is as useless as
his liberal views that's what I
genuinely believe because if he's not
going to respect Muslims and Muslims
views then why should we respect him why
should we respect his reviews like in
nor does he need to
respect us for reviews nor do we need to
respect him and his views you know Allah
it says in the Quran you know you have
your Deen you have your way we have ours
that's it let's move on and if it comes
to that then it comes to that
yes
truth come on bro
he said Destiny's trash Oh trash yeah
his name is the Ugly Truth guys come on
okay stop stop putting Destiny comments
up because it's useless people are just
using us like as an emotional oh this
one's good this one's good that's facts
not debate but more so I have a
discussion because I've been seeing a
lot of debates going around and this is
just my opinion Romney you you used to
be an avid debater as an intellectual
back in the day correct me if uh you can
correct me if I'm wrong but I think a
lot of debates do more harm than good
now yeah I didn't understand this before
when I would tell you yo Rami let's do
another debate bro I want you to destroy
a Christian but I get it no I really do
it's such a headache bro anything that's
framed as a debate most of the time it's
it's just something that's bad even like
back in the day like comes to sources
versus Professor Krause these are both
you know distinguished people Professor
Krauss is an actual
um I'm pretty sure he's a PhD he's a
physicist like you know but he was so
insulting he was so disrespectful and
it's like if that is if that's what a
debate does like why even go through it
and I think that's what a lot of like
the the that is they realize that when
you debate people you have to be very
particular about who you debate it's
something I learned from Muhammad hijab
and Ham's resources as well and maybe
even be wary of the bass I'm always down
to discuss with someone you know
publicly privately whatever I'm always
down to chat but as soon as it is framed
as a debate or it becomes a debate a lot
of the time ugly stuff comes out to just
debate tactics and
low blows and stuff like that yeah yeah
but it's like you said man even right
now talking to the guy I don't even know
how beneficial that would be because it
doesn't seem like he's receptive it
doesn't seem like he's trying to
understand doesn't seem like he wants to
have anything good from it if anything
it just seems like he's trying to attack
it and trying to low blow it and he's
going to try to find something to arise
some kind of emotional response within
us and within the viewers so I just
don't see the point to be honest yeah
and that's a good note and and that
actually brings light I think that
really helps me clarify what I want to
say it's not always going to be like
this it's just right now with all the
heat that's going on all the hate he's
getting I don't think it's very
practical to assume that okay yeah he's
gonna have a chill nice discussion I
think he's going to bottle up a lot of
what he's heard from other people and be
angry and it's going to probably come
out in a discussion right now maybe
sometime in the future
I don't think it's going to be
productive and also I want to mention
like as people who live in a liberal
Society there are things that are
programmed into all of us that are
taught to all of us whether you're
Muslim or not so even discussing certain
topics you're putting yourself as a at a
disadvantage because all he has to do is
insult you make you look bad you know
use whatever fallacy or presentism and
and ethnocentris and ethnocentrism and
whatever he wants to use to throw it at
you throw it at you from The High Ground
because that's what he has as Muslims we
in certain discussions like we are at a
disadvantage right and sometimes it's
not enough to say listen 1400 years ago
that's what they did if you live 1400
years ago you'd be doing the same thing
people don't care for that people don't
understand that they're just thinking
this is what I was taught this is what I
know you're wrong you're wrong you're
wrong
what is it going to do really
knows best and Allah knows best that's
how we're going to end today's stream on
salafi t-talk inshallah we will join you
guys within a week inshallah we're just
going to figure out our streaming
schedule today
um and yeah anything else that you two
want to talk about
um again
may Allah bless you guys immensely don't
insult anyone I think we should end with
the Dua because the prophet sallallahu
he used to part ways from sahaba with
making Dua so do any of you guys want to
make Dua or should I jump in
I don't know but it's kind of simple
it's not like one of the long-founded
ones it doesn't need to be anything
crazy bro don't have to be long bro
foreign
do you have the translation for us
uh
forgot man the the compliments go out to
the brother who's teaching me Arabic
let me pull that up right away bro
because I know it but I don't want to
say it out of ignorance so yeah
if I remember correctly it's basically
asking Allah for forgiveness if you said
or did anything that transgressed in
that time you were speaking
yeah so it says oh thanks and praises to
Allah
Luis To You O Allah and praise I bear
witness that there is none worthy of
worship but you I seek your forgiveness
and turn to you in Repentance and Allah
Knows Best
knows this is
and with that being said may Allah bless
you guys all immensely
we'll see you guys on the next one